ein fünf jahre altes mädchen spielt bei
einer familienfeier am ufer eines
badesees verschwindet dann plötzlich
spurlos bis dann klar wird das kind ist
im seat uhr hannes radigk unser reporter
ist jetzt dort am unglücksort am tempo
sehr wir wollen mit ihnen darüber
sprechen was dort während dieser
familienfeier passiert sein könnte denn
es sollte ein wunderschöner sommerabend
dort werden und das mädchen war offenbar
dann spielen am steg und dann wurde sie
nur kurz aus den augen verloren stunden
später wurde sie tot aus dem wasser
geborgen ich kann hannes habe ich jetzt
auch sehen jetzt zum unglücksort geeilt
hannes was kannst du uns über den
unglückshergang berichten
gestern abend soll es hier in der
gaststätte am bootshaus hinter mir eine
familienfeier gegeben haben und gegen
18.40 sollen die eltern von der lena ihr
auto beladen haben und offensichtlich
beim leben beschäftigt gewesen sein mit
dem beladen des fahrzeugs und
als sie fertig waren haben sie
festgestellt dass das kind nicht da ist
haben dann sofort die suche eingeleitet
und später wurde das kind dann
stieg im wasser
kann ist das ist wirklich der horror für
jedes elternpaar mutter wie auch vater
auch meine urängste sind es dass meine
kinder ertrinken könnten reicht ja schon
eine pfütze hier war es dieser see
kannst du berichten ob die eltern in
irgendeiner form schuld daran tragen
dass sie das kind aus den augen gelassen
haben oder war das wirklich nur so ein
ganz kurzer moment nehmen das kind dann
unbeobachtet diesen
also die polizei jetzt bisher ausgegeben
hat ist das ein fremdverschulden
ausgeschlossen wird und dass eventuell
eben der verdacht
der aufsichtspflicht im raum besteht und
haben nur sagen jeder der selber kinder
hat der weiß dass man kinder nicht 24
stunden bewachen kann und gerade wenn
man eben wenn die situation nicht
wirklich so war dass die eltern ihr auto
beladen haben dass sich das minuten
vielleicht wenn man kurz in der rausgeht
und dann wieder am hofe raum ist da ist
das unmöglich dass man sein kind
lückenlos im auge behält und natürlich
kann ein kind in dem alter hat sie soll
ja die lena gebe es fünf jahre alt sein
genau weiß es noch nicht
das ist nicht möglich also ich würde
diese armen eltern können jeglicher
schuld frei sprechen wenn es sich so
zugetragen hat wie ich eben jetzt
zurzeit gehen das habe ich kann nur
sagen wir erleben gerade den
schrecklichsten tag ihres lebens und
hoffe dass sie dass sie freunde und
verwandte haben die zur seite steht die
kraft geben denn es ist das schlimmste
wenn eltern ihr kind verlieren und
müssen eltern mein herzliches beileid
aussprechen und linke das selber sehr
nahe hier gerade an dieser stelle zu
spät bis dann irgendwie
absolut hannes absolut es ist wirklich
ein hassverbrechen das drama danke dir
für deine bewegenden schilderungen